well some changes at floyd land park are
drawing some criticism from locals new
devices known as goosebusters have been
set up in some of the trees as a way to
control geese in the area madison
kimbrough was at the park today and has
the story
welcome to floyd land park at thule
springs described as an escape from the
typical las vegas atmosphere with its
scenic views and array of different
wildlife from a mixture of geese ducks
and peacocks this is a definitely a gem
seeing like what we have here at the gym
and want to take care of it but the city
just installed what's called a
goosebuster to keep these geese away and
park goers we spoke to aren't for it i
feel like with this whole ghostbuster
thing now
i feel it's just kind of like
starting to take away from one of
the best part of the park
it's the animals this woman who visits
the park often says in the last year
she's noticed less and less geese
hanging around i started noticing all
the differences and them worrying about
where the geese were in the particular
park right around the time that the
events that are
the old historic hay barn was passed in
a statement we received from the city
the hope is that this device will safely
direct these animals from the grassy
areas to the pond to limit the number of
them around picnic areas thus keeping
the park clean and visitors safe but
locals like giovanni who came to the
park tuesday for a picnic says he
worries that with these new devices in
place it will cause harm to the goslings
especially since now is hatching season
from what i've been told right we don't
want to separate
the hatchlings from their their parents
don't deter them right we don't want to
mess with the ecosystem right everybody
poops so do the animals
i'd say deal with it madison kimbrough
live local now